Coral reefs occupy less than a quarter
of one percent of the ocean,
yet are home to a quarter of all marine life.
Each coral is comprised of hundreds
to thousands of individual polyps
all attached to a rock-hard
skeleton that they form.
But exactly how corals construct
these stony skeletons has long been debated
Is it a straightforward chemical process
that reflects environmental conditions
or do the coral polyps exert some control
through their biology?
To answer this question,
researchers studied Stylophora pistillata -
a wide-spread stony coral
found in the Indian and Pacific oceans.
Using high-tech imaging,
they found that corals secrete acid-rich proteins,
which encourage the precipitation
of a form of calcium carbonate known as aragonite.
Each day, the corals secrete enough of these proteins
to leave more than 5 microns of stony coating.
If you watched a coral growing in a tank at this rate,
you would see at least 1 mm of growth in 250 days.
Researchers also found that these acid-rich
proteins
can function within a relatively wide pH range
and may be able to adapt to new conditions
as their ocean home becomes more acidic
due to climate change.
Because of their control over the protein
secretion
and the ability to respond or not to different conditions,
these findings strongly suggest that
coral skeleton-building is largely biological.
Coral reefs can still be affected by other
factors, such as
rising ocean temperatures and nutrient pollution
but at least for now we know
corals are the captain of their own ship